[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump's trip to Asia
continues and bluntly he should stay
there and not come back
NBC reports Bob Muller has enough
evidence to indict Trump's former
right-hand man Mike Flynn and Mike
Flynn's son and Mulder is squeezing the
general as we speak the so called
paradise papers revealed that trumps
antediluvian Secretary of Commerce
Wilbur Ross shares business interests
with members of Putin's inner circle
including Putin's son-in-law and he
didn't tell the Senators who confirmed
him the same document dump reveals Jared
Kushner has another undisclosed link to
Russia his business partner a man named
Yuri Milner who reportedly took millions
of Kremlin money and invested it in
Facebook and Twitter
now Bloomberg News has interviewed the
Russian lawyer who met with Kushner and
Trump jr. and mana Ford in June 2016
and she says she is willing to testify
to the Senate Judiciary Committee and to
Muller
that she told them of alleged donations
to the Clinton campaign that originated
as Russian investments and she lobbied
to overturn an anti-russian American law
- which she says Trump jr. told her
quote if we come to power we can return
to this issue meanwhile Trump again has
insisted in an interview that aired
Sunday that he will be cleared of any
possible Russian conspiracy charges
he told Sinclair propaganda that quote I
am truly not involved in any form of
collusion with Russia believe me that's
the last thing I can think of to be
involved in the time for euphemisms is
over we don't believe Donald Trump on
Russia nobody can believe Donald Trump
any longer any serious thoughtful
analysis of reality can produce only
these assessments Trump is lying
Trump is surrounded by individuals who
are alleged to be already corrupted or
compromised by Russia and Putin Trump is
up to his neck in collusion allegations
of criminal conspiracy with Russia and
the only way he is not at least morally
guilty is if he is totally without
sanity or intellectual capacity there
are so many contacts proved or reliably
reported between the Russians and
Trump staffers and Trump himself that
they seem to implicate almost every
recognizable name from the Trump
campaign and a lot of them from the
Trump administration Trump is lying
Trump appears to be guilty to freshly
remind ourselves how totally intertwined
manipulated by entangled with Putin and
other Russians Trump's campaign was and
Trump's administration is let's just
review this start with when and Flynn
jr. and Wilbur Ross last week it was
mana Ford and his business partner Rick
Gates and George papadopolis and while
they're trying to dismiss Papadopoulos
as a meaningless volunteer on March 21st
2016 Trump listed his first five foreign
policy advisers and Papadopoulos was one
of them and ten days later Trump was at
the table when Papadopoulos adamantly
pitched setting up a meeting between the
Trump campaign and Putin or Trump
himself and Putin and Trump tweeted a
photo of them together
Trump has now said he doesn't quote
remember much about that meeting it was
a very unimportant meeting took place a
long time ago don't remember much about
it he said that nine days after
announcing he has quote one of the great
memories of all time Trump's team now
implies Papadopoulos was discouraged
from following up on the Putin meeting
idea which is I guess why according to
Papadopoulos is guilty plea nobody
stopped him when he met three times with
this Russian length professor or had at
least 17 online exchanges with him or
others form or by phone or by Skype and
on April 26 the professor met with
Papadopoulos and said he was just back
from meeting with high-level Russian
government officials and the professor
told Papadopoulos that the Russians told
him quote they have dirt on her quote
the Russians had emails of Clinton quote
they have thousands of emails 38 days
after that Donald Trump jr. was
contacted with an offer of a meeting at
which he would receive Clinton dirt via
an intermediary from the Russian
government
he brought Kushner and Matt afford to
the meeting and she reportedly brought
talking points that duplicated a set of
talking points given to California
congressman Dana Rohrabacher two months
earlier by the Kremlin
when the story of that meeting with the
lawyer breaks 394 days later Trump jr.
will issue a false cover story that the
meeting was exclusively about adoptions
of Russian kids the White House will
soon admit that the present on Air Force
One quote weighed in on the composing of
that false cover story Washington Post
sources say he dictated that false cover
story himself either way doing either
thing Trump made that into a White House
cover-up of a trump campaign meeting
about joining a Russian conspiracy to
illegally influence the campaign that
ended in Trump's election
Carter page met with Russian government
figures in Moscow he testified he only
said hello to them but he emailed
somebody else in the Trump campaign
about insights gained from these
Russians while he was saying hello and
he says he told jeff sessions about the
meetings jeff sessions will forget all
about this during his confirmation
hearings as attorney general and in fact
he will claim he had no knowledge of
anybody on the Trump campaign having any
contact with Russians but sessions
himself met with the Russian ambassador
kiss lyac at the Republican convention
in Cleveland general Flynn met with kiss
slack in Washington Kushner met with
kiss Lee act in the u.s. to try to set
up a secret communications link directly
to the Kremlin Trump met with kis lyac
after Trump's first foreign policy
speech in Washington Trump met with kis
lyac again and other Russians in the
Oval Office with no American media
present Trump met with Putin at the g20
summit in Hamburg with no Americans
present with nobody else privy to their
conversations except Putin's own
translator WikiLeaks Julian Assange
confirmed he was asked to find and
provide Clinton emails by the CEO of
Cambridge analytic a company once owned
in part by Steve Bannon and months later
Trump donor Rebecca Mercer reportedly
contacted that same CEO and asked him to
find Clinton emails Republican donor
Peter Smith told The Wall Street Journal
he assembled a team on Labor Day 2016 to
get Clinton's emails ten days after the
interview Smith was found dead in a
Minnesota hotel room
having left a note that reportedly read
no foul play whatsoever in all caps a
staffer for the Iowa Senator Chuck
Grassley Barbara lateen herself a close
associate of Mike Flynn admits to having
begun a hunt to find Clinton's emails on
the so-called dark web in 2015 and she
says she sought financial help to do so
from Newt Gingrich the unofficial
Twitter account of Tennessee Republicans
was later revealed to have in fact been
operated by a Kremlin back Russian troll
farm in the weeks before the election
its anti-clinton propaganda was
personally retweeted by Kellyanne Conway
Brad parse kale
Roger stone Michael Flynn Michael Flynn
jr. and Donald Trump jr. and what was
apparently a related account was
retweeted in September of this year by
Donald Trump himself Trump reacted to
the Russian online sabotage like the
Russian advertising buys that facebook
said reached 126 million Americans by
preparing to apparently outsource
American cybersecurity to Russia
quote Putin and I discussed forming an
impenetrable cybersecurity unit so that
election hacking and many other negative
things will be guarded but of course on
February 16th at a news conference Trump
was asked quote can you say whether you
are aware that anyone who advised your
campaign had contacts with Russia during
the course of the election and Trump's
answer was no nobody that I know of
Flynn Flynn jr. Ross Kushner mana Ford
gates Papadopoulos Trump jr. Rohrabacher
Paige sessions kiss lyac Assange Bannon
Mercer Smith 'la Dean Gingrich Conway
parse Gail Stone Putin we must drop the
euphemisms he lied he was lying
he is lying still the correct answer to
that question is not no nobody that I
know of it's closer to yes everybody
that I know of everybody I am truly not
involved in any form of coal
with Russia believe me we don't resign
resist remove peace my book is out at
stores and online
ask work by name well given the title
use your own judgment on that